you know two weeks Melissa since the
hurricane you can still break the
activities down to three different
points you've got rebuilding and cleanup
and that is largely happening by
individuals happening by hand you have
restoration of power that's the big job
and it's happening very slowly and you
still have the distribution of aid more
than two weeks out and from that we get
some remarkable stories not the least of
which is coming from the FBI's elite
hostage rescue team and their tactical
helicopter unit they were out here with
the helicopters they ran into a private
sector donor who had aid and voluntarily
changed their mission and what the guys
in the helicopter unit did is they just
flew around till they could find open
soccer fields open baseball diamonds and
they would put the helicopters down and
hand out all the food water medicine
that they could get their hands on and
sadly what I hear from the agents in
that particular unit is there is still a
tremendous need for aid particularly in
the remote towns and the center of the
island high up in the mountains where
there are bad roads the trucks still
aren't getting to that Melissa
it's Sandra Mike but that's alright the
gua taka
dam everybody's talking about this Mike
what is the status of that dam at this
point the guava taka damage still the
biggest threat for a big catastrophic
failure if you will that dam hadn't been
updated since the 80s and during the
course of the hurricane the output pipes
Jam which was one problem you also had a
tremendous amount of water coming into
the reservoir so he had all this water
that went over the spillway it's
supposed to go over the spillway but it
just never handled this kind of volume
before such a volume of water came
through so fast and the spillway itself
really had some structural issues and it
undermined and ripped out the bottom
half of the spillway and thus is
starting to erode back that spillway in
the bottom of the dam and the bottom the
foundation of that spillway is pretty
much sand if it erodes all the way up to
the dam you could be talking about a
catastrophic failure of the dam which
would flood the hundreds of families
down below so what the Navy pilots and
Marines on the ground are doing is
they're hooking up those big old jersey
barriers to a ch-53 helicopter and they
drop it at the foot of that spillway to
make a big pile of rocks if they can
make that
big enough it'll shore up the foundation
of that spillway in theory anyway and
stop the erosion